Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. member of this company of four libertines. Almost 60 years of age and singularly worn down by debauchery, he was barely more than a skeleton. He was tall, wizened, gaunt, with sunken and dimmed eyes, a livid and sickly mouth a prominent chin a long nose as her suit as a satire with a flat back and flabby buttocks that sagged so much they seemed more like two dirty rags flopping over his thighs the skin there so withered by lashes of the whip one could wrap it around one's finger without his noticing. And in the middle of all this, one could see, without having to spread...
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。这个由四个浪荡子组成的团体的成员。他年近六十，因放荡而显得格外憔悴，几乎只剩下一副骨架。他身材高大，面容枯槁，形容消瘦，双眼深陷而黯淡，嘴唇青紫病态，下巴突出，鼻子很长，就像讽刺画中的人物，背部平坦，臀部松弛下垂，看起来更像是挂在大腿上的两块脏抹布，那里的皮肤被鞭子抽打得如此干瘪，以至于人们可以把它缠在手指上而他却毫无察觉。而在这一切之中，人们可以看到，无需张开……
Oh, Tom, I can't read this. This will destroy the rest of his history. It's literally a filthy passage. Yes, it is literally a very, very filthy passage. Yes, from perhaps the most revolting and shocking novel ever written. So it's by the Marquis de Sade. Yeah. An absolute byword, of course, for sexual depravity.
噢，汤姆，我读不下去。这会毁了《历史的余味》。这简直是一段肮脏的文字。是的，这确实是一段非常、非常肮脏的文字。是的，它可能出自有史以来最令人作呕、最令人震惊的小说。所以这是萨德侯爵写的。没错。当然，他绝对是性堕落的代名词。
And the novel is The 120 Days of Sodom, which I've tried to read several times and I've never managed to finish because it is so disgusting. Yeah. It's simultaneously disgusting, deeply unsettling, boring, and yet at moments very darkly funny. That's what people say of this podcast, Tom. Right.
这部小说就是《索多玛120天》，我试过读好几次，但从来没能读完，因为它太恶心了。没错。它既恶心、令人深感不安、枯燥乏味，却又在某些时刻显得非常黑色幽默。汤姆，人们对这个播客也是这么说的。没错。
So the plot of 120 Days of Sodom is the four libertines. Sorry, Dom. I was about to say, just before you get into the plot, we should probably say right at the outset, if you're listening with people under the age of what? 40? Yeah. This is not a suitable topic. So, you know,
所以《索多玛120天》的情节是关于四个浪荡子。抱歉，多姆。我正想说，在你进入情节之前，我们应该在一开始就说明，如果你和未满……多少岁的人一起听？40岁？是的。这不是一个合适的话题。所以，你知道，
if you're doing the school run listening to this podcast, I think maybe history's greatest dogs would be a... Or pigeons. Yeah, a better subject. Love Island. Exactly.
如果你在开车送孩子上学的路上听这个播客，我想也许“历史上最伟大的狗”会是一个……或者鸽子。是的，一个更好的主题。或者《恋爱岛》。没错。
But anyway, now that those people have had a chance to depart the podcast, 120 Days of Sodom. Tom, boring, disgusting, darkly funny, etc., etc. Described by Sartre himself
但无论如何，既然那些人已经有机会离开这个播客了，《索多玛120天》。汤姆，枯燥、恶心、黑色幽默等等。萨特本人将其描述为
as the most impure tale ever written since the world began, which I think is no exaggeration. And it describes four libertines who retire to a castle called Silling, which is absolutely remote, inaccessible, up on a mountainous crag. Once they've got in there, they demolish the bridge, which is the only point of entry, as it were, into the castle. And they're there with assorted servants and aged prostitutes who will relate them stories, kind of like the Arabian Nights or Canterbury Tales or something like that. Various people who are sexually proficient, who will be able to stage, I mean, absolutely baroque sexual positionings and various people who have been chosen as their victims. And it is, I mean, it's unreadable by the end. It's unreadable. This is 1780s, right?
“自世界开创以来写出的最不纯洁的故事”，我认为这并不夸张。它描述了四个浪荡子隐居到一座名为西林（Silling）的城堡，那里极其偏远、难以进入，位于险峻的山崖之上。一旦进入，他们就拆毁了通往城堡的唯一桥梁。他们和各种仆人以及年迈的妓女待在一起，这些妓女会给他们讲故事，有点像《一千零一夜》或《坎特伯雷故事集》之类的。还有各种在性方面精通的人，他们能够安排，我是说，绝对巴洛克式的性姿势，以及各种被选为受害者的人。我是说，读到最后简直无法卒读。这可是1780年代的作品，对吧？
Well, he writes it in the Bastille. Wow. And this is why I think that the Marquis de Sade is actually a really fascinating topic of discussion. Because although, in fact, because he is so disgusting, because he is so unsettling, he pushes boundaries in a way that no one else has really done. But he's also a person who is kind of situated at an elliptical sense at some of the great events in French history. So he's imprisoned in the Bastille by a lettre de cachet, which are these letters that also serve to imprison the man in the iron mask, issued by the king. If they get served on you, you just get locked up without a
嗯，他在巴士底狱写的。哇。这就是为什么我认为萨德侯爵实际上是一个非常引人入胜的讨论话题。因为尽管，事实上，因为他太恶心了，因为他太令人不安了，他以一种无人能及的方式突破了界限。但他也是一个在法国历史上一些重大事件中处于某种椭圆位置的人。所以他被国王签发的“密札”（lettre de cachet）关进了巴士底狱，这些密札也曾被用来关押“铁面人”。如果这些密札送达你手中，你就会被直接关起来，无需
trial. So the Marquis de Sade is a victim of that. He then gets liberated after the revolution from imprisonment and serves as a very enthusiastic proponent of the revolution, gets monstered by Rose Pierre, gets locked up again, narrowly avoids the guillotine, and ends up being sent to a lunatic asylum on the orders of Napoleon's head of police. So he has the distinction of being imprisoned by the Ancien Régime, Robespierre, and Napoleon. So I think that that makes him an interesting figure. But above all, it's these novels in which, I mean, revolting scenes of sex and violence, and they really are unspeakably revolting. So revolting that I don't really even want to hint at them,
审判。所以萨德侯爵就是其中的受害者。他在大革命后被释放，并成为大革命非常热情的支持者，后来被罗伯斯庇尔迫害，再次被关押，险些躲过断头台，最终在拿破仑警察局长的命令下被送进了精神病院。所以他有一个特点，就是被旧制度、罗伯斯庇尔和拿破仑分别关押过。所以我认为这使他成为一个有趣的人物。但最重要的是，这些小说中，我是说，那些令人作呕的性和暴力场景，它们确实是难以言表的恶心。恶心到我甚至不想暗示它们，
but they alternate with great wadges of philosophy. The philosophy is incredibly unsettling. It pushes elements within the Enlightenment to extremes that foreshadow some of the more unsettling developments in the 19th and 20th century. It's been said by various scholars, say from Saint-Berve in the 19th century, Mario Pras in the 20th century, that Sade is one of the great subterranean influences on the development of European culture and thought. That he's underground, that he's banned, that he's very hard to read, but those who do read him can be quite profoundly influenced by him. And I would argue that he is actually the most accurate and disturbing prophet of certainly totalitarian regimes that there is perhaps apart from Dostoevsky. And he prefigures elements of Darwin's teachings, of Nietzsche's teachings, of Freud's teaching. So I think he is a figure who is worth
但它们与大量的哲学论述交替出现。这些哲学令人极其不安。它将启蒙运动中的某些元素推向了极端，预示了19世纪和20世纪一些更令人不安的发展。各种学者，比如19世纪的圣伯夫，20世纪的马里奥·普拉兹，都曾说过，萨德是欧洲文化和思想发展中伟大的地下影响者之一。他处于地下，他被禁，他很难读，但那些读过他的人可能会受到他深刻的影响。我认为他实际上是除了陀思妥耶夫斯基之外，最准确、最令人不安的极权政权预言家。他预示了达尔文教义、尼采教义、弗洛伊德教义中的某些元素。所以我认为他是一个值得
having an episode devoted to. So the people you've listed, Tom, I mean, some of these people are, I hate to do this for you, actually, but they feature in your book Dominion as the sort of antagonists, I suppose, to the tradition of Christianity and of compassion and the celebration of victimhood and all those kinds of things. Absolutely. And you see the Marquis de Sade as a key figure in the evolution of this kind of counter-tradition. Well, the Marquis de Sade is a very committed atheist. He detests Christianity, and he detests Christianity in, I think, a very honest way, to the degree that he is not dismissing belief in the Christian God, but trying to hold on to Christian principles and values. He detests those principles and values. And that is what motivates both the sexual escapades in the novels and the philosophy, which is why he is not just a kind of logical endpoint of trends within the Enlightenment, but also a kind of critic of it, I think.
专门做一期节目的历史人物。汤姆，你列举的这些人，我是说，其中一些人，我真不想这么说，但他们在你的书《主宰》（Dominion）中被视为基督教传统、同情心和对受害者赞美等观念的对立面。绝对是。你将萨德侯爵视为这种反传统演变中的关键人物。嗯，萨德侯爵是一个非常坚定的无神论者。他憎恨基督教，而且我认为他以一种非常诚实的方式憎恨基督教，以至于他不是在否定对基督教上帝的信仰，而是在试图坚持基督教原则和价值观的同时，憎恨这些原则和价值观。这正是他小说中性冒险和哲学思想的动机，这就是为什么他不仅是启蒙运动趋势的逻辑终点，我认为他也是启蒙运动的批评者。
Jolly good. So let's start by talking a bit about the Marquis de Sade himself. So let's sort of get into the history, the biographical history, as it were. So he's born in June 1740, and I think he's the son of a diplomat. Is that right? Yeah. The Dessards first come to power in the 14th century against the backdrop of the Hundred Years' War that we were talking about a few months ago. And yeah, his father, the Comte Dessard, served as a diplomat in Russia, in Britain. He ended up at the court of the Elector of Cologne.
太好了。那么让我们先谈谈萨德侯爵本人。让我们进入历史，也就是传记历史。他出生于1740年6月，我想他是外交官的儿子。对吗？是的。萨德家族在14世纪我们几个月前谈到的百年战争背景下首次掌权。是的，他的父亲萨德伯爵曾在俄罗斯和英国担任外交官。他最终在科隆选帝侯的宫廷任职。
And he and his brother, who was an abbé, are kind of classic Enlightenment figures. The father was a friend of Voltaire. The abbé de Sade, very, very sophisticated man, very sophisticated library. Sade relied on it a lot. And in the great tradition of French philosophical pornography in the 18th century was a great kind of roue and rake. It's telling that there isn't a churchman in the Marquis de Sade's novels who is not an unspeakable pervert, including the Pope in one spectacular scene where they have an orgy on the altar of St. Peter's.
他和他的兄弟，一位神父，都是典型的启蒙运动人物。他的父亲是伏尔泰的朋友。萨德神父是一个非常、非常世故的人，拥有非常丰富的藏书。萨德非常依赖这些藏书。在18世纪法国哲学色情文学的伟大传统中，他是一个伟大的浪荡子和花花公子。值得注意的是，萨德侯爵的小说中没有一个神职人员不是不可救药的变态，包括教皇，在其中一个壮观的场景中，他们在圣彼得大教堂的祭坛上举行了狂欢派对。
The de Sades have an ancestral castle in Provence, a place called Lacoste, but the Marquis de Sade is not actually born there. He's born in Paris because his mother is quite well connected. So she is a distant relative to the Princess de Condé, who's a very, very grand figure. And Sade's mother, she's a kind of lady-in-waiting in the Condé Palace in Paris. And that is where Sade is born and it's where he's brought up up. He is brought up together with the Prince de Condé, who's going to grow up to be a great figure. It looks like Sade is in pole position for a brilliant career, except that at the age of four, he punches the Prince de Condé in the face. Throughout his life, Sade has an unbelievable ability to mess things up.
萨德家族在普罗旺斯有一座祖传城堡，一个叫拉科斯特（Lacoste）的地方，但萨德侯爵实际上并不是在那里出生的。他出生在巴黎，因为他的母亲人脉很广。她是孔代亲王妃的远亲，那是一个非常、非常显赫的人物。萨德的母亲是巴黎孔代宫的一名侍女。萨德就是在那儿出生并长大的。他和孔代亲王一起长大，后者后来成为了一位大人物。看起来萨德正处于辉煌事业的起点，但四岁时，他打了孔代亲王一拳。在他的一生中，萨德有一种令人难以置信的把事情搞砸的能力。
He writes about it later and says that his spirit was too violent, too aggressive. He's very kind of honest. He understands himself very well. And because of this, because he's punched the prince de Condé in the face, he basically gets banished from Paris and gets sent away. The age of four, that's very harsh. Yeah, sent away to Provence. So that's a blot on his prospects. But an even bigger blot is that his father has been up to no good and he ends up being arrested for various kind of financial improprieties. So his career as a diplomat is destroyed. And the mother basically gives up on both father and son and she retires to a convent in Paris on the aptly named Rue d'Infer, so the Hell Road.
他后来写道，他的精神太暴力、太激进了。他非常诚实。他非常了解自己。正因为如此，因为他打了孔代亲王一拳，他基本上被逐出了巴黎，被送走了。四岁，这太严厉了。是的，被送到了普罗旺斯。所以这对他的前途是一个污点。但更大的污点是他的父亲行为不端，最终因各种财务不当行为被捕。所以他的外交官生涯毁了。他的母亲基本上放弃了丈夫和儿子，退隐到巴黎的一座修道院，那条街的名字很贴切，叫“地狱路”（Rue d'Infer）。
Hell Street, yeah. Yeah. So I wonder, that probably plays some part in the Marquis de Sade's sort of tortured psychology. Yes. And the fact that, again, in his novels, the relationship between parents and children is unvariably violent. Right.
地狱街，没错。是的。所以我怀疑，这可能在萨德侯爵扭曲的心理中起了一定作用。是的。而且事实上，在他的小说中，父母与子女的关系总是暴力的。没错。
Parents kill children, children kill parents. It's a kind of abiding dynamic so i don't think the relationship between them was great you know a psychologist would have a field day and indeed psychologists have had field days with sart so he he gets banished he doesn't actually get brought up in um in la coste but in another of the family castles a place called salman and this is a place with caves dungeons dungeons, there's a fort, and this will very much feed into, I think, the Castle of Silling where the four libertines end up. It's a very Gothic, actually, a very 18th century Gothic. Yeah.
父母杀害子女，子女杀害父母。这是一种持久的动态，所以我认为他们之间的关系并不好，你知道，心理学家会对萨德进行一番研究，事实上，心理学家们确实对萨德进行了大量的研究。所以他被放逐了，他实际上并不是在拉科斯特长大的，而是在家族的另一座城堡，一个叫萨尔曼（Salman）的地方，那里有洞穴、地牢，还有一座堡垒，我认为这在很大程度上影响了《索多玛120天》中四个浪荡子最终居住的西林城堡。这非常哥特，实际上，非常18世纪的哥特风格。是的。
Yeah. Very, very Gothic. From that, he goes back to Paris where he's educated by the Jesuits. Right. Again, there's a sense in which the 120 Days of Sodom is a parody of a Jesuit school, because in the 120 Days of Sodom, it's not pure libertinage. There is a book of rules. There are daily routines. Anyone who breaks the routine gets whipped. Right. Saad is drawing on his memories. I mean, he was whipped a lot at the Jesuit school, and he was very, very resentful of the very, very controlled schedule that existed there. So I think, again, you can see these childhood influences kind of remaining with him.
是的，非常、非常哥特。从那以后，他回到巴黎，接受了耶稣会士的教育。没错。同样，某种程度上，《索多玛120天》是对耶稣会学校的模仿，因为在《索多玛120天》中，这不仅仅是纯粹的放荡。有一本规则书。有日常作息。任何打破作息的人都会被鞭打。没错。萨德借鉴了他的记忆。我是说，他在耶稣会学校经常被鞭打，他对那里存在的非常、非常严格的时间表感到非常、非常怨恨。所以我认为，同样，你可以看到这些童年的影响一直伴随着他。
And then he goes to military school. I mean, again, my boggles. Lamarcki decided at a military school. And then he serves in the Seven Years' War very, very well. He takes part in seven campaigns. And he would boast later that he'd fought well. And I think he had done. Though not, of course, on the winning side. Though not on the winning side, Dominic. No, not on the winning side. But he was never going to have a military career because even while he's a young man serving in the army, his prime interest is debauchery. And so at the age of 19, he wrote to a priest who had been one of his tutors and is absolutely upfront about this and says that every morning he rose to go in search of pleasure and the thought of it made me oblivious to everything else.
然后他去了军校。我是说，再次让我感到震惊。萨德侯爵在军校。然后他在七年战争中服役得非常好。他参加了七次战役。他后来吹嘘自己打得很好。我想他确实做到了。虽然当然不是在获胜的一方。虽然不是在获胜的一方，多米尼克。不，不是在获胜的一方。但他永远不会有军事生涯，因为即使在他年轻时在军队服役期间，他的主要兴趣也是放荡。所以19岁时，他写信给曾是他导师的一位神父，对此非常坦率，他说他每天早上起床去寻找快乐，而对快乐的渴望让他忘记了其他一切。
But that's not necessarily incompatible with the military career. I mean, there must be a lot of sort of hot-blooded young men who are in the French army in the 1750s, 1760s, Tom? Surely that's not a problem. Absolutely. As you'll know, the tradition of libertinage, of debauchery, is something that is very, very manifest in the aristocracy of this period. If you think of dangerous liaisons, the Vicomte de Valmont, they're all looking like John Malkovich, writing letters on the backs of young girls and things like that. You're absolutely looking like John Malkovich, writing letters on the backs of young girls and things like that. So you're absolutely right that this shouldn't have been a problem. It should have
但这并不一定与军事生涯不相容。我是说，1750年代、1760年代的法国军队里一定有很多热血青年，汤姆？这肯定不是问题吧？绝对是。如你所知，放荡的传统在那个时期的贵族中是非常、非常明显的。如果你想到《危险关系》，瓦尔蒙子爵，他们看起来都像约翰·马尔科维奇，在年轻女孩的背上写信之类的。你看起来绝对像约翰·马尔科维奇，在年轻女孩的背上写信之类的。所以你是绝对正确的，这不应该是个问题。这应该是
been perfectly possible for the Marquis de Sade to combine the two. The fact that he doesn't is, I think, because of two things. And the first is that his tastes are clearly very aberrant. So he likes a whipping. I mean, that's not unduly aberrant. So Rousseau liked a whipping. Did he? He did. So it was very, very common. Boys got whipped a lot in childhood. Rousseau got, I think, spanked by a girl and then spent the rest of his life yearning for the experience again, but was too shy to ask for it. Whereas the market side wasn't, and noblemen generally weren't, and it was taken for granted in brothels that there would be whippings because it was seen as a stimulant. It was a kind of equivalent of Viagra.
萨德侯爵完全可以两者兼顾。他没有这样做，我认为是因为两件事。第一件事是他的品味显然非常反常。所以他喜欢鞭打。我是说，这并不算过度反常。卢梭也喜欢鞭打。是吗？他喜欢。所以这非常、非常普遍。男孩在童年时期经常被鞭打。卢梭被一个女孩打了屁股，然后余生都在渴望这种体验，但太害羞而不敢要求。而萨德侯爵不是，贵族们通常也不是，在妓院里鞭打被认为是理所当然的，因为它被视为一种兴奋剂。它是一种类似伟哥的东西。
And the French have the gall to call this the vice anglaise. Yeah, absolutely. But he has other tastes that are illegal, what they would call sodomy. He's very into that both ways. He's a very non-binary figure, to put it in more contemporary phrases. So he likes swapping social roles. He likes swapping gender roles. Okay. You know, with his valet, they'll kind of swap clothes. Sometimes Saad will play the role of a woman with his valet.
法国人竟然有胆量称之为“英国恶习”（vice anglaise）。是的，绝对是。但他还有其他非法的品味，他们称之为鸡奸。他在这两方面都很投入。用更现代的说法，他是一个非常非二元的人物。所以他喜欢交换社会角色。他喜欢交换性别角色。好吧。你知道，他和他的男仆会交换衣服。有时萨德会和他的男仆一起扮演女性的角色。
Yeah. And he likes violence. He clearly enjoys inflicting pain. Right. And indeed having pain inflicted on him. So although the market Saad obviously is associated with sadism, he's given his name to that, there is also clearly a very strong strain of masochism within him. So those are tastes that are going to raise eyebrows if he's not careful. But on top of that, he is interpreting these sexual tastes in a philosophical way.
是的。而且他喜欢暴力。他显然喜欢施加痛苦。没错。而且确实也喜欢承受痛苦。所以尽管萨德侯爵显然与“施虐癖”（sadism）联系在一起，他以自己的名字命名了这种癖好，但他内心显然也有一种非常强烈的受虐倾向。所以这些品味如果他不小心的话，会引起人们的侧目。但最重要的是，他正在以一种哲学的方式解读这些性品味。
Well, I was just about to say, so those tastes alone are surely not enough to damn him because when you think about the stories, I mean, we've talked about them in earlier podcasts about the sort of, I don't know, what are they? The kind of hellfire clubs and the rakes of the 18th century in England. Such extreme licentious sexual misbehaviour is not an automatic social and political disqualification in the 18th century. No. But it's the philosophical stuff, I suppose, that takes that a stage further. I think libertinism was originally a name that was applied to people who were sceptical about religion, about Christianity.
嗯，我正想说，所以单凭这些品味肯定不足以谴责他，因为当你想到那些故事时，我是说，我们在之前的播客中谈论过它们，关于那种，我不知道，它们是什么？18世纪英国的地狱火俱乐部和花花公子。这种极端的放荡性行为在18世纪并不是自动的社会和政治取消资格的理由。不。但我想是哲学方面的东西让它更进一步了。我认为“浪荡主义”（libertinism）最初是一个应用于对宗教、对基督教持怀疑态度的人的名称。
Yeah. So the association of sexual extremes with philosophical extremes is absolutely part of the current. But it's just that the Marxist style pushes it to limits in every way. So it's not just that he's skeptical of religion, he's actively hostile to it. He's violently abusive of Jesus, of the Virgin, really very offensive. He's an out-and-out materialist. He thinks there is no God. Everything is just composed of molecules and there is really only nature. And therefore, if you have impulses, you should follow them. Why should people stop you? There are no inherent
是的。所以将性极端与哲学极端联系起来绝对是当时潮流的一部分。只是萨德侯爵在各个方面都将其推向了极限。所以他不仅对宗教持怀疑态度，而且积极敌视它。他暴力地辱骂耶稣、圣母，真的非常冒犯。他是一个彻底的唯物主义者。他认为没有上帝。一切都只是由分子组成的，真正存在的只有自然。因此，如果你有冲动，你应该跟随它们。为什么人们要阻止你？没有固有的
moral laws that should restrain you. To be true to nature, you do what nature is prompting you to do, which is a very modern understanding of sexuality. Because by and large, the understanding of sexuality was that if you do illegal things, you do it you're bad yeah you've chosen you've chosen chosen to do it right whereas the market start has a very you know our understanding would be that your sexual tastes are part of your core identity in a sense you know you can't really help what they are yeah and that's absolutely what he feels and And he says of his own tastes, he describes them as Baroque, but he says, I always hold them worthy of respect for one is not master of them. And furthermore, he looks at nature and he says, it's the way of nature
道德法则应该约束你。为了忠于自然，你做自然促使你做的事，这是一种非常现代的性理解。因为总的来说，对性的理解是，如果你做非法的事情，你就是坏的，是的，你选择了，你选择了去做，对吧？而萨德侯爵有一种非常，你知道，我们的理解是，你的性品味在某种意义上是你核心身份的一部分，你知道，你无法真正控制它们是什么，是的，这绝对是他所感受到的。而且他谈到自己的品味时，他称它们为巴洛克式的，但他说道：“我总是认为它们值得尊重，因为一个人不是它们的主人。”此外，他观察自然并说，这是自然的方式，
that the strong, the powerful, even the murderous are the ones who have been chosen by nature. So they should have literally the whip hand. So there is your anticipation of what people would see as the wilder shores of Darwinism and Nietzsche. Yeah, absolutely. The celebration of strength, power, competition, aggression, all that stuff. Yes. So it's quite a potent mix. And you can imagine that for any young lady, particularly from a devout bourgeois background, this would be an unsettling man to have as a husband. But this is what happens in 1763. The Sards are on their uppers.
强者、权势者，甚至是杀人犯，才是被自然选择的人。所以他们应该真正掌握鞭子。所以这就是你对人们所认为的达尔文主义和尼采主义更狂野一面的预见。是的，绝对是。对力量、权力、竞争、侵略的赞美，所有这些东西。是的。所以这是一个相当强烈的组合。你可以想象，对于任何年轻女士，特别是来自虔诚资产阶级背景的女性，作为一个丈夫，这是一个令人不安的人。但这就是1763年发生的事情。萨德家族入不敷出。
Comte de Sard, the Marquis de Sard's dad, he's spendthrift. He's short of money. And so basically, he matches up his son with the daughter of a very socially ambitious judge. So the Comte de Sade will get the money, and the family of this girl, Renée Pellagy de Montreuil, will get the social cachet that comes from marrying into the aristocracy. And René comes with a very, very formidable mother-in-law who initially is quite charmed by Sade, by this new son-in-law, but in time will start to lose patience with him. I think very understandably because the fact that he's married in no way inhibits Saad from carrying on exactly as he pleases. And a succession of scandals, kind of royals of the marriage, and over the course of the decades that follow, come to make the market Saad an absolute byword for notoriety. And one
萨德伯爵，萨德侯爵的父亲，他挥霍无度。他缺钱。所以基本上，他把儿子和一个社会野心勃勃的法官的女儿配对。这样萨德伯爵就能得到钱，而这个女孩的家庭，蕾妮·佩拉吉·德·蒙特勒伊（Renée Pellagy de Montreuil），将获得与贵族联姻带来的社会声望。蕾妮带来了一位非常、非常令人生畏的岳母，她最初对萨德，对这个新女婿相当着迷，但随着时间的推移，她开始对他失去耐心。我认为非常可以理解，因为他结婚的事实丝毫没有阻止萨德继续随心所欲。一系列的丑闻，婚姻的动荡，在随后的几十年里，使萨德侯爵成为了臭名昭著的代名词。人们
has to assume that although there are quite a lot of scandals, there must have been a lot going on that was never discovered. So we don't know what he was getting up to all the time. So six months after he's married her, the first of these scandals, he has hired a prostitute called Jeanne Tastard. And what he is reported to have done to her is absolutely classic Marquis de Sade. So he attempts to make her do what I guess the Daily Mail would describe a sick sex act. Oh no. I won't go into any more detail, but he also engages in philosophical blasphemy. So the police report said that he asked her, did she believe in Jesus and the Virgin?
必须假设，尽管有很多丑闻，但肯定还有很多从未被发现的事情。所以我们不知道他一直都在干什么。所以在他结婚六个月后，这些丑闻中的第一起发生了，他雇了一个叫珍妮·塔斯塔德（Jeanne Tastard）的妓女。据报道他对她所做的事情是绝对经典的萨德侯爵式行为。所以他试图让她做我猜《每日邮报》会描述为“变态性行为”的事情。噢，不。我不会再深入细节了，但他还参与了哲学亵渎。所以警方报告说，他问她，她是否相信耶稣和圣母？
And when she said that she did, he replied with horrible insults and blasphemy, saying that there was no God, that he had proved it, that he had masturbated directly into a chalice, declared that Jesus was a bastard and the Virgin was a bitch. That's more than she bargained for, wasn't it? Absolutely. He's got all kinds of crosses. He makes her, again, perform various sex acts with the crucifixes, trample on them, urinate on them. It's simultaneously deviant and blasphemous yeah uh so he gets arrested and he gets sent off to the royal donjon of bassin which is a great royal fortress on the outskirts of paris actually built by philip the wise again who was in our hundred years
当她说她相信时，他用可怕的侮辱和亵渎来回答，说没有上帝，他已经证明了这一点，他在圣餐杯里直接自慰，宣称耶稣是个私生子，圣母是个婊子。这比她预想的要多，不是吗？绝对是。他有各种各样的十字架。他让她，再次，用十字架进行各种性行为，践踏它们，在它们上面小便。这既是离经叛道又是亵渎，是的。所以他被捕了，被送往巴士底狱的皇家地牢，那是一座位于巴黎郊区的伟大皇家堡垒，实际上是由“智者”菲利普建造的，他也是我们百年战争中的人物，
war yes yeah in the 40th century and um it's up to madame de montreuil his mother-in-law to get him out yeah that's a hard one to explain to your mother-in-law, isn't it? So at this point, she's still quite on his side. I mean, I think she thinks he's quite naughty. He's a character. He's a character. He's a child, so he's a lad. So she gets him out and doesn't let her daughter know. So it's still slightly under wraps.
战争，是的，在14世纪。嗯，这取决于他的岳母蒙特勒伊夫人把他救出来。是的，这很难向你的岳母解释，不是吗？在这一点上，她仍然相当站在他这一边。嗯，我想她认为他相当淘气。他是个角色。他是个角色。他是个孩子，所以他是个小伙子。所以她把他救了出来，并没有让她的女儿知道。所以它仍然稍微保密。
But then 1768, on Easter Sunday, and it does seem that Christian festivals bring out the worst in him. He pays a beggar woman called Rose Keller. He invites her in with an offer of working for him as a servant. And he then, well, according to Rose Keller's testimony, he starts cutting her flesh with a knife, pouring wax into the wounds. Sarr denies this, says this is an absolute calumny, insists that he only lashed her with a cat and knife. Oh my God. So that's fine.
但后来1768年，复活节那天，基督教节日似乎确实激发了他最坏的一面。他付钱给一个叫罗斯·凯勒（Rose Keller）的乞丐妇女。他邀请她进来，提出让她为他做仆人。然后他，嗯，根据罗斯·凯勒的证词，他开始用刀割她的肉，把蜡倒进伤口里。萨德否认这一点，说这是绝对的诽谤，坚持说他只是用鞭子抽了她。天哪。所以那没关系。
Right. So again, Madame de Montreuil kind of leaps into action. She's desperate to keep this all hushed up. She pays Rose Keller off and she goes to the king. She goes to the court, has a letter cachet written, and so has Sade imprisoned. So that's a letter that is closed with the seal of the king, she goes to the court, has a letter cachet written, and so has Saad imprisoned. So that's a letter that is closed with the seal of the king. Yes.
没错。所以蒙特勒伊夫人再次采取行动。她拼命想把这一切掩盖起来。她付钱给罗斯·凯勒，然后去找国王。她去宫廷，写了一封密札，于是把萨德关了起来。所以那是一封用国王印章封住的信，她去宫廷，写了一封密札，于是把萨德关了起来。所以那是一封用国王印章封住的信。是的。
Can't be opened. There's no trial. And the reason she does that, I'm guessing, is because she doesn't want the paper trail that would come if he was charged normally. Is that right? Exactly. So she doesn't want it to go to court. So in a way, I mean, she's protecting her daughter's reputation, but she's also protecting Saad himself. But he doesn't see it like that. He sees her as this kind of vengeful harpy who's out to destroy him. And so he's let out after seven months imprisonment, but he is now convinced that she is this kind of baleful figure who wants to destroy him. He leaves Paris, leaves her behind and takes René off with him to Lacoste
不能打开。没有审判。我猜她这样做的原因是因为她不想要如果他被正常起诉而产生的书面记录。对吗？没错。所以她不想让它上法庭。所以某种程度上，我是说，她在保护她女儿的名誉，但她也在保护萨德本人。但他并不这么看。他把她视为那种想要摧毁他的复仇女妖。所以他在七个月的监禁后被释放，但他现在确信她是一个想要摧毁他的邪恶人物。他离开巴黎，把她留在身后，带着蕾妮去了拉科斯特，
in Provence with the understanding that if he misbehaves, he's really going to get into trouble, that the Lecherche is now kind of hanging over him a bit like a guillotine, one might almost say. Because you can't cancel it. Once it's out there, it's- It's ready to be used. Yeah. Exactly. So the Marquis de Sade's approach, and by this point his father's died, so he is by now the Marquis de Sade. His idea of behaving well is to go to Marseille, have a massive orgy with his valet and four
在普罗旺斯，并达成共识，如果他行为不端，他真的会惹上麻烦，密札现在有点像断头台一样悬在他头上，人们几乎可以说。因为你不能取消它。一旦它出去了，它就是——它随时准备被使用。是的。没错。所以萨德侯爵的方法，到这个时候他父亲已经去世了，所以他现在是萨德侯爵。他表现良好的想法是去马赛，和他的男仆以及四个
prostitutes, to do some gender bending with the valet. Right. To, again, commit various sex acts. Right. That are illegal. Yeah. To poison the prostitutes with Spanish fly, which is a kind of aphrodisiac. So he laces chocolate with Spanish fly. Partly it seems
妓女举行一场盛大的狂欢派对，和男仆进行一些性别转换。没错。再次，进行各种性行为。没错。那是违法的。是的。用西班牙苍蝇毒害妓女，这是一种催情药。所以他在巧克力里加了西班牙苍蝇。部分原因似乎
to encourage them to keep going, but also because this gives them bad wind. And one of the things that the marketeer really enjoys is smelling the bottom of a prostitute who's breaking wind. So that's all stacking up. And then he comes back and he runs off with his sister-in-law and Prosper, with whom he's been having an affair under his wife's nose. Well, that's slightly more conventional, isn't it? I mean, it's bad behaviour, but it's conventional. It is, but it's not the kind of thing that's designed, obviously, to thrill his wife or indeed his mother-in-law, who has him arrested again and imprisoned. And he manages to escape in quite a daring escape.
是为了鼓励她们继续，但也因为这会让她们胀气。萨德侯爵真正享受的事情之一就是闻一个正在放屁的妓女的屁股。所以这一切都在堆积。然后他回来了，和他的小姨子普罗斯珀（Prosper）私奔了，他一直在他妻子的眼皮底下和她有染。嗯，那稍微传统一点，不是吗？我是说，这是不好的行为，但它是传统的。是的，但这不是那种显然旨在让他的妻子或他的岳母感到兴奋的事情，他的岳母再次让他被捕并监禁。他设法进行了一次相当大胆的逃跑。
And after his escape, he's almost in hiding, but still getting up to all kinds of carry-ons. And it seems that by 1774, he's very charming. And somehow he's kind of, I suppose you could say corrupted, René. His wife, yeah. If that's not too loaded a word. Huge debate about this, whether she ends up complicit in his orgies. But certainly, the winter of 1774-75, Sade writes to a friend saying, we've decided for a thousand different reasons to see very few people this winter. It's a bad sign, isn't it?
在他逃跑后，他几乎是在躲藏，但仍然在进行各种各样的勾当。似乎到了1774年，他非常有魅力。不知何故，他，我想你可以说，腐蚀了蕾妮。他的妻子，是的。如果这不是一个太沉重的词的话。关于这一点有巨大的争论，她是否最终成了他狂欢派对的同谋。但可以肯定的是，1774-75年的冬天，萨德写信给一位朋友说，我们出于一千个不同的原因决定这个冬天很少见人。这是一个坏兆头，不是吗？
Basically, he and René have retreated to a castle in 120 days of Sodom style, and they've recruited various girls, some of them really quite young, to be servants, they say, to work as housemaids. And in January 1775, the parents of five of these girls bring a formal complaint at Lyon, claiming that basically Sard has abducted their daughters and sard flees to italy when you say quite young they're teenagers they're 15 16 15 yeah he goes to italy hides out there comes back to lacoste there he is almost shot by the father of one of the girls who is in his castle is basically i mean the girl doesn't want to come
基本上，他和蕾妮以《索多玛120天》的风格退隐到一座城堡，他们招募了各种女孩，其中一些真的很年轻，作为仆人，他们说，作为女佣工作。1775年1月，其中五个女孩的父母在里昂提出了正式投诉，声称基本上萨德绑架了他们的女儿，萨德逃到了意大利。当你说是“相当年轻”时，她们是十几岁，她们是15、16岁，15岁，是的。他去了意大利，躲在那里，回到拉科斯特，在那里他差点被他城堡里的一个女孩的父亲枪杀，基本上，我是说，女孩不想回来，
back the father has come to pick his daughter up The girl doesn't want to come back. The father has come to pick his daughter up. The daughter doesn't want to leave. So the father then tries to shoot Sade. So it's all looking quite bad in every way. Then he gets a letter telling him that his mother in Paris is dying. He arrives in Paris to discover that his mother has actually been dead for three months and realizes that it's a trap that's been set for him by his mother-in-law. Again, she's got the letter cachet. This orders his immediate incarceration. In February 1777, he's arrested. He's taken to Vincennes, the great royal donjon where he was before, driven in in a carriage. It's a wintry night. All the soldiers who are on guard avert their eyes. They're not allowed to see who it is who's being brought in. A warning bell is sounded. Gates are unlocked, locked up again. And the Marquis de Sade is imprisoned and
父亲来接他的女儿。女孩不想离开。父亲来接他的女儿。女儿不想离开。所以父亲试图枪杀萨德。所以各方面看起来都很糟糕。然后他收到一封信，告诉他他在巴黎的母亲快要死了。他到达巴黎，发现他的母亲实际上已经死了三个月了，意识到这是他岳母为他设下的陷阱。她再次拿到了密札。这命令立即将他监禁。1777年2月，他被捕。他被带到文森（Vincennes），他之前待过的伟大皇家地牢，坐马车进去。那是一个寒冷的夜晚。所有守卫的士兵都避开了目光。他们不允许看到被带进来的人是谁。警钟响起。大门解锁，再次锁上。萨德侯爵被监禁，
becomes Monsieur Numéro 11, Monsieur Number 11. And he will spend the next 13 years of his life in prison. That's where we should leave it. I think we should take a break now. And then we'll return. I mean, he hasn't really written anything yet, has he? So when we return, we'll be able to talk about his adventures in the French Revolution under Napoleon. And you can talk us through the Marquis de Sade's ideas. Some of them, yeah. And make your case for why he matters,
成为了“11号先生”（Monsieur Numéro 11）。他将在监狱里度过余生13年。我们应该在那里停下来。我想我们现在应该休息一下。然后我们会回来。我是说，他还没真正写过什么，对吧？所以当我们回来时，我们将能够谈论他在法国大革命期间在拿破仑统治下的冒险经历。你可以带我们了解萨德侯爵的思想。其中一些，是的。并说明为什么他很重要，
why we should take him seriously as a historic figure. Yeah. So join us after the break for more sadism. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. a historic figure. So join us to the rest is history we're talking about the marquis de sade um as we said in the first half not a subject for the school run i mean if your children have been listening to the first half you're all in now so you might as well just carry on. But social services are on their way. Tom, Marquis de Sade has just been imprisoned and he stays there for 13 years. Is that right? He stays in Bassem for seven years. And then in 1784, he gets transferred to the Bastille,
为什么我们应该把他视为一个历史人物。是的。所以休息后加入我们，了解更多关于施虐癖的内容。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。一个历史人物。所以加入我们《历史的余味》，我们正在谈论萨德侯爵，嗯，正如我们在上半部分所说，这不是一个适合送孩子上学时听的主题，我是说，如果你的孩子一直在听上半部分，你们现在都在里面了，所以你们不妨继续听下去。但社会服务部门正在赶来的路上。汤姆，萨德侯爵刚刚被监禁，他在那里待了13年。对吗？他在文森待了七年。然后在1784年，他被转移到巴士底狱，
the notorious prison in the heart of Paris. And throughout this time, his only real correspondence is René, his wife. And he's very imperious with her. He sends her out on kind of shopping missions for eel pâté, apricot marmalade. And he, well, can I say this on the podcast? I don't know. What are you going to say? Kind of butt plugs. Oh, right. Very precise measurements. He's very finickety about this. Are these being manufactured in 18th century Paris? No wonder they had a revolution, Tom. I think part of the fun of it for the marketer's art isn't just getting the plug on its own, but making his very devout wife go and ask for it. It's bespoke. Right. You wouldn't get this kind of behavior from Pitt the Younger, would you? Absolutely not. No.
那座位于巴黎市中心的臭名昭著的监狱。在这段时间里，他唯一真正的通信对象是蕾妮，他的妻子。他对她非常专横。他派她去执行各种购物任务，买鳗鱼肉酱、杏子果酱。还有他，嗯，我能在播客上说这个吗？我不知道。你要说什么？某种肛门塞。噢，没错。非常精确的测量。他对此非常挑剔。这些是在18世纪的巴黎制造的吗？难怪他们会发生革命，汤姆。我认为萨德侯爵从中得到的乐趣之一不仅仅是得到那个塞子本身，而是让非常虔诚的妻子去要求它。它是定制的。没错。你不会从老皮特（Pitt the Younger）那里得到这种行为，对吧？绝对不会。不。
And you've said just before the end of the first half that he hasn't really written much by this point, but he writes voluminously in prison and particularly in the Bastille. And that is where he writes 120 Days of Sodom, which he writes in this kind of great fever of creativity, 37 days at the end of 1785. As we said, it's the most shocking novel ever written, and it's designed to become ever more shocking. So one of the things that's quite funny about the novel is that he includes within it lists of things that he's done wrong, which you'd think maybe quite a lot of novels could do, where the author says, actually, I got this bit wrong. And one of the notes he makes is that he should have toned down the first part. So in other words,
你刚才在第一部分结束前说，他到目前为止还没有写太多东西，但他确实在监狱里，特别是在巴士底狱里写了大量的作品。那就是他写《索多玛120天》的地方，他是在一种巨大的创作狂热中写下的，1785年底的37天里。正如我们所说，这是有史以来最令人震惊的小说，它旨在变得越来越令人震惊。所以关于这部小说，相当有趣的一点是，他在其中包含了自己做错的事情的清单，你可能会认为也许很多小说都能做到这一点，作者说，实际上，我把这一部分写错了。他做出的笔记之一是，他应该淡化第一部分。换句话说，
he goes in, as it were, too hard because the design of the book is that it should become escalatingly horrific. And it culminates with horrific murders. I mean, horrible murders. And so as you're reading it, you know that you're kind of getting this sense of crescendo towards absolute violence, darkness, nihilism. And this is why I think in the aftermath of the Second World War, he was so interesting to so many people in France. So many kind of philosophers and thinkers kind of identified the 120 Days of Sodom as a kind of prophecy of the Gestapo, of torture camps and death camps. Because it's the story of these four libertines who basically,
他进入得太猛了，因为这本书的设计是它应该变得越来越恐怖。它以可怕的谋杀告终。我是说，可怕的谋杀。所以当你读它时，你知道你正在感受到这种向绝对暴力、黑暗、虚无主义的渐强。这就是为什么我认为在第二次世界大战之后，他在法国受到这么多人的关注。这么多哲学家和思想家将《索多玛120天》视为盖世太保、酷刑营和死亡集中营的预言。因为这是关于那四个浪荡子的故事，基本上，
they're shacked up in this castle and they imprison a vast number of people and subject them to all kinds of horrible kind of tortures. Yes. And so the most famous cinematic adaptation of 120 Days of Sodom is by Pasolini, the great Italian director. It's the last film he made called Sarlow, which was the plot of 120 Days of Sodom set in the final fascist republic before Mussolini's death. Well, that's a constant obsession, isn't it? The idea that fascism and sadism and sexual sadism, sexual deviance are part of the same
他们躲在这座城堡里，囚禁了大量的人，并对他们施加了各种可怕的酷刑。是的。所以《索多玛120天》最著名的电影改编是帕索里尼（Pasolini），伟大的意大利导演。这是他拍摄的最后一部电影，叫《萨罗》（Salo），这是《索多玛120天》的情节，背景设定在墨索里尼死前的最后一个法西斯共和国。嗯，那是一个持续的痴迷，不是吗？法西斯主义、施虐癖、性施虐癖、性变态是同一种
sort of mixture. And I think one of the things that kind of justifies this take is the way that I mentioned before, that actually the castle in 120 Days of Sodom is run like a Jesuit school. So it's this attempt to impose order on absolute horror, which of course you get in Auschwitz. You know, the trains, the timetables, the mechanized processes. And I think that it's that that people in the aftermath of the Second World War, when they looked at 120 Days of Sodom, were struck by. So the sort of methodically regulated obscenity, basically. Yeah. And actually, Sartre loses the manuscript of 120 Days of Sodom. He's written it in secret, very, very small hand, hides it in the brickwork, but loses
混合物的一部分。我认为证明这种观点合理的事情之一是我之前提到的，实际上《索多玛120天》中的城堡管理得像一所耶稣会学校。所以这是一种试图将秩序强加于绝对恐怖的尝试，当然你在奥斯威辛集中营也能看到。你知道，火车、时刻表、机械化的过程。我认为正是这一点让第二次世界大战后的人们在看《索多玛120天》时感到震惊。所以基本上是那种有条不紊的受控淫秽。是的。实际上，萨特丢失了《索多玛120天》的手稿。他秘密地用非常、非常小的字写下它，把它藏在砖墙里，但丢失了
it because he gets overtaken by the events of the French Revolution. So the governor of the Bastille on the 2nd of July 1789, as the streets of Paris are becoming ever more, you know, starting to seethe, he wrote to a friend and reported that the Marquis de Sade had appeared at the window of his cell and shouted with all his strength and being heard by the entire neighborhood and by passers-by that they were slaughtering and assassinating the prisoners of the Bastille and that people should come to their aid. It's absolutely classic Marquis de Sade that the way he's able to be heard shouting from his window is that he takes what was called a pissing tube. So it was a kind of piece of metal that the prisoner would have to piss through out into
它，因为他被法国大革命的事件所超越。所以1789年7月2日，当巴黎的街道变得越来越，你知道，开始沸腾时，巴士底狱的典狱长写信给一位朋友，报告说萨德侯爵出现在他牢房的窗前，用尽全力大喊，整个街区和路人都听到了，说他们正在屠杀和暗杀巴士底狱的囚犯，人们应该来帮助他们。这绝对是经典的萨德侯爵，他能够从窗户大喊大叫的方式是他拿了一个所谓的“小便管”。所以那是一种囚犯必须通过它小便到外面的金属片。
the sewer down below. So he's shouting through that. And this does play a part in inciting the mob that two days later will ransack the Bastille and end up chopping the head of the governor off and parading around on a spike. But by that point, the marketer's side himself is not there because he's been transferred. He gets taken to an asylum for the insane at a place called Charenton, again on the outskirts of Paris. And he loses the manuscript of 120 days. While he's being transferred. Yeah. Just a quick question there, Tom. So he's transferred to a lunatic asylum.
下方的下水道。所以他在那里大喊大叫。这确实在煽动两天后洗劫巴士底狱的暴民中起到了作用，他们最终砍下了监狱长的头，并用长矛挑着游行。但到那时，萨德侯爵本人并不在那里，因为他已经被转移了。他被带到了巴黎郊外一个叫沙朗通的精神病院。在转移过程中，他弄丢了《索多玛120天》的手稿。是的。汤姆，有个小问题。所以他被转移到了精神病院。
You wouldn't say he was a lunatic, would you? You'd say he was completely irrational. Yes, I think so. I mean, I wouldn't say that he was normal, but I think that saying he's mad is a kind of cop-out. But I think the fact that he keeps being transferred, he's either being imprisoned or transferred to asylums, does suggest that it doesn't matter whether it's the monarchical regime or the revolution regime, people find him very, very difficult to cope with. But with the revolution, he can play the part of someone who'd suffered from despotic tyranny. And so in spring 1790, he's freed. He doesn't go back to René because by this point, René has become deeply religious and deeply upset by his
你不会说他是疯子，对吧？你会说他完全不理智。是的，我想是这样。我的意思是，我不会说他正常，但我认为说他疯了是一种逃避。但我认为他不断被转移，要么被监禁，要么被送进精神病院的事实确实表明，无论是在君主制政权还是革命政权下，人们都觉得他非常、非常难以应付。但在革命时期，他可以扮演一个遭受专制暴政迫害的人的角色。所以1790年春天，他被释放了。他没有回到蕾妮身边，因为此时蕾妮已经变得非常虔诚，并且对他
arguments. So he refuses to see him and in fact divorces him two months after his release. And on top of that, he has money problems because of course, he's an aristocrat in a revolutionary world. So he tries to make money by his pen. He writes writes a play. It gets staged for one night. Predictably, there's a massive riot. The theatre gets smashed up. And he's writing various novels, most famously Justine, The Sufferings of Virtue, which we'll come to a bit later. But again, he hasn't lost his charm, despite the fact that while he was in the Bastille, he'd actually become quite obese. He hitches up with a former actress called Marie Constance Quinet. But what he really does is throw himself into revolutionary politics because he has this certain degree of prestige from having been a prisoner in the Bastille.
的论点感到非常不安。所以她拒绝见他，事实上在他获释两个月后就和他离婚了。最重要的是，他有经济问题，因为他毕竟是革命世界里的贵族。所以他试图靠笔杆子赚钱。他写了一部剧本。上演了一晚。不出所料，发生了大规模骚乱。剧院被砸毁了。他还在写各种小说，最著名的是《瑞斯丁：美德的不幸》，我们稍后会谈到。但同样，尽管他在巴士底狱时已经变得相当肥胖，但他并没有失去魅力。他与一位前女演员玛丽·康斯坦斯·基内走到了一起。但他真正做的是投身于革命政治，因为他曾是巴士底狱的囚犯，这让他拥有了一定的声望。
So he casts himself as Citoyen Sade, Citizen Sade, and he registers himself in the most radical quarter of Paris. So the Place de Vendôme, which later comes to be called the Section des Piques. And this is the kind of the stamping ground of Rosepierre himself. And Sade seems to actually have done this with some commitment and some sense of duty. I mean, he gets voted onto a three-man committee that is charged with inspecting girls' orphanages. That's a terrible, terrible mistake, surely. Me, the market Assad, the girls' orphanage. What were they thinking? Oh, no.
于是他自称萨德公民，并在巴黎最激进的街区注册。也就是旺多姆广场，后来被称为长矛区。这是罗伯斯庇尔本人的大本营。萨德似乎确实是带着某种承诺和责任感这样做的。我的意思是，他被选入了一个负责视察女子孤儿院的三人委员会。这肯定是一个非常、非常可怕的错误。我是说，萨德侯爵，女子孤儿院。他们到底在想什么？哦，不。
But he actually, I mean, he seems to have executed his duties responsibly. He leads an inquiry into hospital conditions, again, with great responsibility. And the really fascinating example of the way that he seems not to have allowed his violent fantasies to influence his behavior as a kind of revolutionary official is that he ends up being elected president of the Selection de Pique. And in that role, he has to work out who should be sent for trial as enemies of the revolution, who shouldn't. And on the list of people who could conceivably be sent to trial are his in-laws, and he doesn't send them to trial. Right. So he doesn't seek revenge on his mother-in-law, who had him in prison for 13 years. No, he doesn't. To his credit, I think.
但他实际上，我的意思是，他似乎负责任地履行了他的职责。他领导了一项关于医院状况的调查，同样非常负责。他似乎没有让自己的暴力幻想影响他作为革命官员的行为，一个非常迷人的例子是，他最终被选为长矛区的主席。在那个职位上，他必须决定谁应该被送去审判作为革命的敌人，谁不应该。而在可能被送去审判的人员名单中，有他的姻亲，但他没有把他们送去审判。对。所以他没有向那个让他坐了13年牢的岳母报复。不，他没有。我认为这归功于他。
Yeah. He doesn't behave at all as a monster during the revolutionary period, quite the opposite, in fact. And it may be that that is actually the sense that perhaps he's too soft, ironically, is what leads to his downfall because it seems that Robespierre decides that he is a counter-revolutionary. And so December 1794, he's jailed in the horrible conditions that the suspects are put into during the height of the terror. For six weeks, he said, I slept in the toilet with seven other people.
是的。在革命期间，他表现得一点也不像个怪物，事实上恰恰相反。可能正是因为这种感觉，也许他太软弱了，讽刺的是，这导致了他的垮台，因为罗伯斯庇尔似乎认定他是反革命分子。所以1794年12月，他被关进了恐怖统治时期嫌疑人所处的恶劣环境中。他说，六个星期里，我和另外七个人睡在厕所里。
And he's imprisoned, why? Because he was a former aristocrat or because he has been behaving badly again with servants and so on? No, it's not behaving badly. He is accused of being a very immoral suspect man, unfit for society, but that's based on records from decades previously. You know, all the various escapades he'd been going through before his imprisonment. Right.
他被监禁，为什么？因为他曾是贵族，还是因为他又在仆人等方面表现恶劣？不，不是表现恶劣。他被指控为一个非常不道德的嫌疑人，不适合社会，但这基于几十年前的记录。你知道，他在入狱前经历过的各种冒险。对。
He is an aristocrat, so that counts against him. And also he has had sons, and some of these sons have gone abroad to serve with the counter-revolutionary forces. So again, that isn't a good look for him. So with that against his name at the height of the terror, I mean, it looks really terrible. So Marie Constance, his partner, is able to kind of dole out bribes and get him moved to a better prison, a former convent in Picpus. And that is where, almost directly under his window, the guillotine gets set up. It gets removed from the Place de la Concorde and set up underneath his window. And so he's smelling the blood that's spilling out from the guillotine. Yeah. Because this is the height of the terror. I think you said it was December 1794, but it's 1793, isn't it, when he's jailed?
他是贵族，所以这对他不利。而且他还有儿子，其中一些儿子出国为反革命势力效力。所以，这对他来说也不是什么好形象。因此，在恐怖统治的高峰期，这对他来说确实非常糟糕。所以他的伴侣玛丽·康斯坦斯能够通过贿赂让他被转移到更好的监狱，即皮克普斯的一所前修道院。就在那里，几乎就在他的窗下，断头台被架设起来了。它从协和广场被移走，架设在他的窗下。所以他闻到了从断头台上流出的血腥味。是的。因为这是恐怖统治的高峰。我想你说的是1794年12月，但应该是1793年，他被关押的时候，对吧？
Sorry, yes. Yeah. So, I mean, this is the point at which the revolution is beleaguered within and without. They're searching for enemies. So you can completely see why they would identify somebody like him, an aberrant figure, an aristocratic figure, as an enemy within, I suppose. Yeah. And amazingly, he is sentenced for execution on the 27th of July, 1794. He avoids being taken away. And it may be that that, again, is because Marie Constance has a judicious bribe, but it's also luck because the 27th of July, 1794 is the day that Rose Pierre is overthrown and executed the following day. So effectively,
抱歉，是的。是的。所以，我的意思是，这是革命在内外受困的时刻。他们正在寻找敌人。所以我完全明白为什么他们会把像他这样的人，一个反常的人物，一个贵族人物，视为内部敌人。是的。令人惊讶的是，他在1794年7月27日被判处死刑。他避免了被带走。这可能再次是因为玛丽·康斯坦斯进行了明智的贿赂，但这也是运气，因为1794年7月27日是罗伯斯庇尔被推翻并于次日被处决的日子。所以实际上，
it's the end of the Terror. Crikey, it is, isn't it? It's Termidor. It's the climax of the French Revolution in some ways. So he's that close to execution. But again, having been in the Bastille just before it stormed, he's at the heart of the Terror when Rose-Pierre is executed. He's set free October 1794. Right. And this is when the At the heart of the terror when Rose Pierre is executed, he's set free October 1794. And this is when the terror is kind of subsiding. So he can lead a moderately normal life from this point on. But he's absolutely kind of skint.
这是恐怖统治的终结。天哪，确实是这样，不是吗？这是热月政变。在某种程度上，这是法国大革命的高潮。所以他离死刑只有一步之遥。但同样，在巴士底狱被攻占前夕他就在那里，在罗伯斯庇尔被处决时，他正处于恐怖统治的核心。他于1794年10月获释。对。这就是当罗伯斯庇尔被处决时，他正处于恐怖统治的核心，他于1794年10月获释。这就是恐怖统治开始消退的时候。所以从那时起，他可以过上相对正常的生活。但他绝对是身无分文。
He hasn't really got any money at all. He gets a job as a prompter at the theater in Versailles. He sells Lacoste in 1796, his ancestral home. He's endlessly kind of trying to catch money off people. And he starts writing novels again. And the most notorious novel, as I mentioned before, is this novel Justine. There are various iterations of it. He just kind of keeps writing and writing and writing it. And basically it's a parody. It's a parody of a novel by the English writer, Samuel Richardson, Pamela. And this is a story of a virtuous girl whose virtue ends up being rewarded. The twist in Justine is that she's incredibly virtuous,
他真的没有任何钱。他在凡尔赛的剧院找到了一份提词员的工作。他在1796年卖掉了祖宅拉科斯特。他不断地试图从别人那里弄钱。他又开始写小说了。正如我之前提到的，最臭名昭著的小说是《瑞斯丁》。它有各种版本。他只是不断地写啊写啊写。基本上它是一个模仿作品。它是对英国作家塞缪尔·理查森的小说《帕梅拉》的模仿。这是一个关于一个美德少女的故事，她的美德最终得到了回报。《瑞斯丁》的转折在于她极其有美德，
and every time she does something good, awful things happen to her. Meanwhile, she has a sister, Juliet, who is the embodiment of vice. And every time she does something awful, she reaps enormous fortunes. The one time in the novel where Juliet hesitates to commit an atrocity is where her partner, a kind of Bicomte de Valmont, John Malkovich figure, is proposing to poison the wells across France and wipe out half the population just for fun. She hesitates, and he notices, and she plunges into ruin. She learns that lesson, and from that point on, she never shows a scruple of conscience ever again and rises up to become terribly successful. And in the original version, she runs into Justine as her sister is being taken to execution because she's been
每当她做一件好事，可怕的事情就会发生在她身上。与此同时，她有一个妹妹朱丽叶，她是邪恶的化身。每当她做一件可怕的事情，她就会获得巨大的财富。在小说中，朱丽叶唯一一次犹豫是否要犯下暴行，是她的伴侣，一个类似瓦尔蒙子爵、约翰·马尔科维奇式的人物，提议在法国各地投毒，为了好玩消灭一半人口的时候。她犹豫了，他注意到了，她陷入了毁灭。她吸取了教训，从那时起，她再也没有表现出任何良心上的顾虑，并崛起成为非常成功的人。在最初的版本中，她遇到了瑞斯丁，当时她的妹妹正被带去处决，因为她一直
virtuous and she's been sentenced illegally by corrupt judges. And Juliet rescues her, sets her free. Justine walks off and is struck by lightning through the heart so what's interesting about this is that this is at a point when virtue the idea of virtue has become so central to the french revolutionary project hasn't it yeah so actually somebody like robespierre we were talking about a second ago i mean robespierre absolutely believes in this sort of the dictatorship of virtue. Yes, he does. So for Sade to be mocking this is counter-revolutionary, actually. It's undermining the entire revolutionary project in the mid-1790s. It absolutely is. So it's very shocking. And Sade
很有美德，却被腐败的法官非法判刑。朱丽叶救了她，放了她。瑞斯丁走开了，心脏被闪电击中。所以有趣的是，这正是在美德，美德的概念在法国革命计划中变得如此核心的时候，不是吗？是的。所以实际上像罗伯斯庇尔这样的人，我们刚才谈到的，我的意思是罗伯斯庇尔绝对相信这种美德的独裁。是的，他相信。所以萨德嘲笑这一点是反革命的，实际上。这在18世纪90年代中期破坏了整个革命计划。确实如此。所以这非常令人震惊。而萨德
has not published it under his name, although he's dedicated to Marie Constance, which you think might give it away. But it becomes very, very notorious. And in due course, after Napoleon's come to power, his chief of police, Joseph Fouché, is instructed by Napoleon to basically clean up the publishing industry. He launches a raid on Sade's publisher where a copy of Justine is being bound with pornographic illustrations. And they track Sade down. And he's convicted, sent to prison,
并没有以他的名字出版它，尽管他把它献给了玛丽·康斯坦斯，你可能会认为这会泄露身份。但它变得非常、非常臭名昭著。在拿破仑掌权后，他的警察局长约瑟夫·富歇受拿破仑指示，基本上要清理出版业。他们对萨德的出版商进行了突击搜查，当时一本《瑞斯丁》正被装订，里面有色情插图。他们追踪到了萨德。他被定罪，送进监狱，
and then transferred back to Charenton, the lunatic asylum in 1803. And he stays there for the rest of his life. Conditions there are not so bad. He gets on very well with the superintendent of the asylum, allows Saad to stage plays. He's still absolutely up to his old tricks. So in 1803, there's a kind of, the guards go through his room and they discover, and I quote, an enormous instrument that he fashioned out of wax and which he used on himself since the instrument retained some traces of its shameful intromission. Oh my word. Right. Yes is 17. He's 74. So absolute tradition of the 120 days of Sodom. He's 74. He seems to have aged very quickly, but of course he spent such vast tracts of his life in prison. He spent decades in prison. He dies on the 1st of December, 1814. Even before he's died, his fame is immense and international in scope. How do people know about him, Tom? I suppose it's equivalent to the dark web. Those who know where to look will find him. Lady Byron,
然后在1803年被转移回沙朗通精神病院。他在那里度过了余生。那里的条件还不错。他和精神病院的院长相处得很好，院长允许萨德上演剧本。他依然完全在玩他的老把戏。所以1803年，守卫搜查了他的房间，他们发现了一个，我引用，“他用蜡制作的巨大工具，他一直对自己使用，因为该工具保留了一些可耻插入的痕迹。”天哪。对。是的，他74岁了。所以绝对是《索多玛120天》的传统。他74岁了。他似乎老得很快，但当然他在监狱里度过了他生命中如此漫长的时光。他在监狱里度过了几十年。他于1814年12月1日去世。甚至在他去世之前，他的名声就已经巨大且具有国际影响力。汤姆，人们是怎么知道他的？我想这相当于暗网。那些知道去哪里找的人会找到他。拜伦夫人，
for instance, amid the scandal of Byron's divorce, claims to have found a copy of Justine in Byron's trunk. And actually, Sade is paired with Byron a lot by critics in the 19th century and 20th century as being one of the two most influential figures on 19th century culture. So perhaps having given his life, I should now justify the claim that actually he has a significance beyond simply the biographical, because he does prefigure some of the more unsettling trends for conventional 19th century figures. So Darwin would be a classic. I should say less Darwin than Darwinists, people who interpret Darwin crudely. Yeah. So you don't mean Darwin as it were, the biologist. You mean the sort of bastardised, popularized Darwinism.
例如，在拜伦离婚的丑闻中，声称在拜伦的行李箱里发现了一本《瑞斯丁》。事实上，萨德在19世纪和20世纪的评论家中经常与拜伦相提并论，被认为是19世纪文化中最具影响力的两个人之一。所以也许在讲述了他的生平之后，我现在应该证明这个主张，即他确实具有超越单纯传记的意义，因为他确实预示了传统19世纪人物的一些更令人不安的趋势。所以达尔文就是一个典型的例子。我应该说与其说是达尔文，不如说是达尔文主义者，那些粗俗地解释达尔文的人。是的。所以你不是指达尔文，也就是生物学家。你指的是那种被歪曲的、大众化的达尔文主义。
Survival of the fittest, which is coined by Darwin's own cousin and is being propagated within months of the publication of The Origin of Species. But Sartre has prefigured all that because he has this materialist sense of nature that all his molecules and molecules are endlessly churning and that what nature wants is a kind of turnover of molecules. So this is why nature fosters war and murder. And therefore, war and murder from the standpoint of nature is absolutely desirable. And that this in turn means that nature privileges the strong. So Sade in one of his novels writes that wolves eating lambs, lambs devoured by wolves, the strong killing the weak, the weak falling victim to the strong. Such is nature. Such are
适者生存，这是达尔文的表弟创造的，在《物种起源》出版后的几个月内就开始传播了。但萨德预示了这一切，因为他有一种物质主义的自然观，即他所有的分子和分子都在不断地搅动，自然想要的是一种分子的更替。这就是为什么自然助长战争和谋杀。因此，从自然的立场来看，战争和谋杀是绝对可取的。这意味着自然偏爱强者。所以萨德在他的一部小说中写道，狼吃羊，羊被狼吞噬，强者杀弱者，弱者沦为强者的牺牲品。这就是自然。这就是
her designs. Such is her plan. So that is a very radical prefiguring of what will become Darwinist trends. But I mean, that quotation, I'm thinking back to that podcast we did about the intellectual origins of Nazism in the late 19th century. It's sort of Houston, Stuart Chamberlain and all the sort of racist manifestos of the 1880s, 1890s. You could well imagine those words being written and coming from one of those manifestos, couldn't you? You absolutely could. And that sort of bastardized Darwinism is absolutely something that feeds into Nazism, as is, again, the bastardized understanding of Nietzsche. And Sade is the great prefigurer of Nietzsche. So just as Nietzsche very radically rejects not just the Christian God, but Christian values, so Sade has already blazed that path. I said that he is contemptuous of
她的设计。这就是她的计划。所以这是对后来成为达尔文主义趋势的非常激进的预示。但是，我的意思是，那段引文，我回想起我们做的关于19世纪末纳粹主义知识起源的播客。那是休斯顿·斯图尔特·张伯伦和19世纪80年代、90年代所有那种种族主义宣言。你可以想象那些话是被写出来的，并出自那些宣言之一，不是吗？你绝对可以。那种被歪曲的达尔文主义绝对是滋养纳粹主义的东西，就像对尼采的被歪曲的理解一样。而萨德是尼采伟大的预示者。所以正如尼采非常激进地拒绝的不仅仅是基督教上帝，而是基督教价值观，萨德已经开辟了那条道路。我说过他蔑视
Jesus as a figure, which I think is unusual for atheists. Most atheists are pretty respectful of Jesus, even if they don't think he's divine. But Sade describes him as a leprous Jew born of a whore. He describes, again, Christianity in very Nietzschean terms as a slave religion. So this is a speech from a Ruhe in Justine, that Christianity represents the weak and the speak and sound like them. Nothing surprising in this, but that he who is neither weak nor Christian subject himself to such restrictions, voluntarily entangle himself in this mythical snarl of brotherly relationships, which without benefiting him the least, deprive him enormously. It's unthinkable. So Sade is absolutely claiming that the idea that, you know, love your neighbor, love your enemy,
耶稣这个人物，我认为这对无神论者来说是不寻常的。大多数无神论者对耶稣相当尊重，即使他们不认为他是神圣的。但萨德形容他是一个妓女生的麻风病犹太人。他再次以非常尼采的术语形容基督教为奴隶宗教。所以这是《瑞斯丁》中鲁赫的一段演讲，基督教代表了弱者，听起来像他们。这没什么好奇怪的，但那个既不软弱也不信基督教的人，自愿服从这种限制，自愿陷入这种兄弟关系的神秘纠葛中，这对他一点好处都没有，却剥夺了他很多。这是不可想象的。所以萨德绝对是在声称，那种“爱你的邻居，爱你的敌人”的想法，
that this is not in nature. It's purely contingent, bred of Christian slaves. This in turn leads him to argue that there is no absolute morality, that different countries and different times have had different understandings of morality, therefore there is no absolute morality, therefore people are free to do as they please." This is the argument that he'd made repeatedly to Renée as she was becoming more devout, and which leads her in the end to reject and divorce him. When we were talking about Columbus and we were talking about the very different moral frameworks that existed on either side of the Atlantic, Sade fixes on this. He says that to forgive one's enemies is a virtue among Christian imbeciles. In Brazil, it is sought a splendid act to kill and eat them.
这在自然界中是不存在的。它纯粹是偶然的，是基督教奴隶培育出来的。这反过来导致他争辩说没有绝对的道德，不同的国家和不同的时代对道德有不同的理解，因此没有绝对的道德，因此人们可以自由地做他们想做的事。这是他反复向蕾妮提出的论点，当时她变得越来越虔诚，这最终导致她拒绝并与他离婚。当我们谈论哥伦布时，我们谈论大西洋两岸存在的截然不同的道德框架，萨德就抓住了这一点。他说，宽恕敌人是基督教白痴中的一种美德。在巴西，杀掉并吃掉他们被视为一种壮举。
Right. That may or may not be true, but Sade undoubtedly is fixing on something, which is that Christian ideals are not culturally absolute. How much is he saying this to shock? I think he completely believes it. He completely believes it. He returns to it again and again and again. Okay. And therefore, because culture is relative, Sade's argument is that ultimately you can only trust what you yourself feel and the promptings of your own impulses and above all your sexual desires. Oh, that's very 21st century, isn't it?
对。这可能是真的，也可能不是，但萨德无疑是在关注一点，那就是基督教理想并非文化上的绝对。他说这些话有多少是为了震惊？我认为他完全相信这一点。他完全相信。他一次又一次地回到这一点。好的。因此，因为文化是相对的，萨德的论点是，最终你只能相信你自己的感受和你自己冲动的驱使，尤其是你的性欲望。哦，那非常21世纪，不是吗？
Well, it is. Yes. Feeling, trumping thought. Yeah. He lives his truth. And so this also is what makes him interesting to the psychoanalytical movement as it starts to develop. In fact, Richard von Krafft-Ebbing, who writes this great scientific analysis of different deviances, as he called them, perversions, he's the guy who coins the word sadism from the Marquis de Sade. He sees 120 Days of Sodom as a work of science rather than as a work of fiction, which is a kind of, I suppose, a kind of taming of Sade in a way, a sense that Sade is not merely a bogeyman.
嗯，是的。感觉胜过思想。是的。他活出了他的真实。所以这也使他成为精神分析运动开始发展时感兴趣的对象。事实上，理查德·冯·克拉夫特-埃宾，他写了这篇关于不同偏差的伟大科学分析，正如他所称的，变态，他就是从萨德侯爵那里创造了“施虐癖”这个词的人。他把《索多玛120天》视为一部科学著作，而不是一部虚构作品，这在某种程度上，我想，是一种对萨德的驯服，一种萨德不仅仅是一个妖怪的感觉。
Because Krafft Ebbing and in Duke Calls Freud accept Sade's proposition that sexual identity is fundamental to your broader identity, and that in a way it is bad to suppress your desires. I mean, the idea of the ego and the id is kind of implicit in Sade's writings. And in the 20th century, this makes Sade seem very cutting edge, very exciting. And the idea of him as someone who refused to be tamed by convention. Apollinaire, the great French poet in the early 20th century, described him as the freest spirit who had ever lived. He stands at the head of a distinctively French tradition, which casts Sade as a great intellectual hero. He's very influential on Foucault. I was about to say, Michel Foucault is very clearly influenced by
因为克拉夫特-埃宾和后来的弗洛伊德接受了萨德的命题，即性身份是你更广泛身份的基础，在某种程度上，压抑你的欲望是不好的。我的意思是，自我和本我的概念在萨德的著作中是隐含的。在20世纪，这使得萨德看起来非常前卫，非常令人兴奋。他作为一个拒绝被习俗驯服的人的想法。阿波利奈尔，20世纪初伟大的法国诗人，形容他是“有史以来最自由的精神”。他站在独特的法国传统的首位，将萨德塑造为一位伟大的知识英雄。他对福柯非常有影响力。我正要说，米歇尔·福柯显然受到了
the fascination of power with violence. And prisons. Yeah, and prisons. And asylums. Yeah. But also, intriguingly, feminists have been fascinated by him and seen Sade as a proto-feminist because Sade did absolutely see women as being equal to men in terms of
权力对暴力的迷恋的影响。还有监狱。是的，还有监狱。还有精神病院。是的。但同样有趣的是，女权主义者一直对他很着迷，并将萨德视为原始女权主义者，因为萨德确实将女性视为在平等程度上与男性平等的人。
what they could do. Juliet, for instance, is a monster, and that facade is a kind of source of privilege. So, I mean, Simon de Beauvoir, Angela Carter, Camille Paglia, they've all kind of feted Sartre in a kind of very strange way. What will have already occurred to, I'm sure, to lots of listeners, and this does sound like a French intellectual thing to do, is they appear to have slightly overlooked the fact that there are an awful lot of poor beggars, servant girls, teenage girls, and so on, who are façade, the objects, the instruments. Yes. That don't have the agency, maybe, think they palliate it. And actually the feminist who really has no time
他们能做什么。例如，朱丽叶是一个怪物，萨德的这种身份是一种特权的来源。所以，我的意思是，西蒙娜·德·波伏娃、安吉拉·卡特、卡米尔·帕利亚，她们都以一种非常奇怪的方式赞美萨德。我相信很多听众已经想到了，这听起来确实像法国知识分子的做法，她们似乎稍微忽略了一个事实，即有大量的穷苦乞丐、女仆、少女等等，她们是萨德的对象、工具。是的。她们没有代理权，也许认为她们减轻了它。事实上，真正没有时间
for Sade is Andrea Dworkin, who was very robust on all these kinds of issues. But you're right, that there is a kind of weird way in which Sade has been cast as actually as a progressive. And you might think, how could this be possible? The answer I think is focused in a particular section of a novel he wrote called Philosophy in the Boudoir, which in a way is the perfect phrase for summing up what Sade is all about. In it, he writes this little essay called Yet Another Effort, Frenchmen, If You Would Become Republicans. He's writing this in the revolutionary period. Basically, he is trying to construct a framework of morals that can be rooted in nature rather than in the inheritance
理会萨德的女权主义者是安德里亚·德沃金，她在所有这些问题上都非常强硬。但你是对的，萨德确实以一种奇怪的方式被塑造成了一个进步人士。你可能会想，这怎么可能？我认为答案集中在他写的一部名为《闺房哲学》的小说中的特定章节，这在某种程度上是总结萨德全部内容的完美短语。在其中，他写了这篇名为《法国人，如果你们想成为共和党人，还需要再努力》的小论文。他是在革命时期写这篇文章的。基本上，他试图构建一个可以植根于自然而不是基督教遗产的道德框架，
of Christianity, which is being thrown aside as a legacy of despotism. And he argues for absolutely impeccably progressive principles. So he is against the death penalty, as Robespierre was, of course. He's absolutely in favor of female liberation, thinks women should have absolute equality, that women should have a right to abortion, that what we would call gay rights, that gay people should have absolute equality before the law, all of which make him sound like a kind of 21st century progressive. But what makes him unsettling for the 21st century as for the 18th and 19th century is that he then starts to push these principles to incredibly unsettling ends. I mean, in a way, when he talks about the
基督教作为专制主义的遗产正在被抛弃。他主张绝对无可挑剔的进步原则。所以他反对死刑，当然罗伯斯庇尔也是。他绝对赞成女性解放，认为女性应该拥有绝对平等，女性应该有堕胎权，我们所说的同性恋权利，同性恋者应该在法律面前拥有绝对平等，所有这些都使他听起来像一个21世纪的进步人士。但让他对21世纪以及18世纪和19世纪感到不安的是，他随后开始将这些原则推向令人难以置信的令人不安的结局。我的意思是，在某种程度上，当他谈到
fact that there should be absolute tolerance, he goes further. And rather like trans campaigners now, there's the assumption that a properly revolutionary and progressive state should constantly be looking for frontiers to push back, that there will always be people who are suffering because of their sexuality or their gender identity or whatever, and that it's the responsibility of a progressive state to push and push and push this forward, to undermine what convention calls virtuous and normal. Inevitably, being the Marquis de Sade, he starts to argue that there should be no limit to tolerance for sexual desire at all, so therefore rape should be legitimate, that incest should be legitimate. This is particularly the case for a society like
应该有绝对的宽容时，他走得更远。就像现在的跨性别活动家一样，有一种假设，即一个适当的革命和进步的国家应该不断地寻找要推翻的边界，总会有因为他们的性取向或性别认同等而受苦的人，而进步国家的责任就是推动、推动、再推动这一点，以破坏习俗所称的美德和正常。不可避免地，作为萨德侯爵，他开始争辩说，对性欲望的宽容应该没有限制，因此强奸应该是合法的，乱伦应该是合法的。对于像
revolutionary France, which is founded on the ideal of fraternity. He's turning the political ideals on its head. He then starts arguing that murder sustains republican virtue, that nature requires constant change and replenishment. And he ends up basically arguing for genocide. So he praises the spectacle in China of children's corpses clogging rivers and declares that it is both necessary and politic to erect barriers to population growth in a republican government so what's quite interesting tom is he's writing this in the 1790s at a point when yes you know your saint just or your robespierre they are in their rhetoric are sometimes not far short of that yes their calls for constant terror their insistence that blood must be spilled to maintain the purity of the revolution. Assad is pushing that to its ultimate extreme, but it's not unrooted in the circumstances of the day. Yes. And he's admiring the spectacle of dead children dying of starvation in China. And that in due course is what will come to happen under Mao in the name of virtue, of communist ideals, and of course, under Stalin as well in Ukraine. So there is absolutely a prefiguring
革命法国这样建立在博爱理想之上的社会，情况尤其如此。他正在颠倒政治理想。他随后开始争辩说，谋杀维持了共和美德，自然需要不断的改变和补充。他最终基本上是在为种族灭绝辩护。所以他赞美中国儿童尸体堵塞河流的景象，并宣称在共和政府中建立人口增长障碍既必要又合乎政治。所以汤姆，非常有趣的是，他在18世纪90年代写这篇文章时，是的，你知道你的圣茹斯特或你的罗伯斯庇尔，他们的言辞有时离那并不远。是的，他们呼吁不断的恐怖，他们坚持必须流血以维持革命的纯洁性。萨德正在将其推向极致，但这并非没有植根于当时的状况。是的。他正在欣赏中国儿童死于饥饿的景象。而这在适当的时候，正是毛泽东时代以美德、共产主义理想的名义，当然还有斯大林在乌克兰所发生的事情。所以绝对有一个预示
there of communist totalitarianism. But of course, there is also a prefiguring of, as we've said before, of fascist totalitarianism. So just like the fascists, he looks back to Rome and to the ancient world for examples of how states can organize themselves without Christianity. He has this theory that the Roman Empire fell because Christians came in and forbade people watching spectacles of torture and death in the arena and it turned the Romans into slaves. Gibbon famously had suggested in The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire that the adoption of Christianity was one of his causes. It's basically implied, hadn't it? It was one of the causes of the decline of Rome from the glories of the Antonine Age. This is only a few decades after Gibbon was writing, right?
在那里，共产主义极权主义。但当然，正如我们之前所说，也有法西斯极权主义的预示。所以就像法西斯分子一样，他回顾罗马和古代世界，寻找国家如何在没有基督教的情况下组织自己的例子。他有一个理论，罗马帝国之所以灭亡，是因为基督徒进入并禁止人们观看竞技场中的酷刑和死亡表演，这把罗马人变成了奴隶。吉本在《罗马帝国衰亡史》中著名地暗示，基督教的采用是其原因之一。这基本上是暗示，不是吗？这是罗马从安东尼时代的辉煌中衰落的原因之一。这距离吉本写作只有几十年，对吧？
Yes, but it's a much sharper version. He further extrapolates that because they went soft, therefore they were no longer willing to tolerate that bastards, orphans, deformed children should be put to death at birth, which of course is what the Nazis will do. And in absolutely Sardian terms. And when in his novels, Sard is citing ancient sources as justification for the principle that society is made up only of the weak and the strong, that charity is cold and pointless, that the weak should be left to die.
是的，但这是一个更尖锐的版本。他进一步推断，因为他们变得软弱，所以他们不再愿意容忍私生子、孤儿、畸形儿童在出生时被处死，这当然是纳粹会做的事情。而且是以绝对的萨德式术语。当萨德在他的小说中引用古代资料作为社会仅由弱者和强者组成、慈善是冷酷且毫无意义的、弱者应该被任其死亡这一原则的辩护时。
He's basically doing what the Nazis do. Just as he has provided arguments for why, say, a soi-disant progressive state could license genocide, he also provides a license for genocide that the fascists would have recognized. So he is a very unsettling figure, I think, and remains an unsettling figure. It's interesting how he contains so much. So as you say, prefiguring the ethos of fascism, the moral ethos of fascism or something, but also in his emphasis on nature dictates your desires to lead an authentic, properly virtuous life, I suppose.
他基本上是在做纳粹所做的事情。正如他为为什么一个所谓的进步国家可以许可种族灭绝提供了论据一样，他也为法西斯分子会认可的种族灭绝提供了许可。所以他是一个非常令人不安的人物，我认为，并且仍然是一个令人不安的人物。有趣的是他包含了这么多东西。所以正如你所说，预示了法西斯主义的精神，法西斯主义的道德精神或类似的东西，但也强调自然决定了你的欲望，以过上真实、适当美德的生活，我想。
You should act on those desires and for society to try to contain them is wrong and all that sort of stuff. I mean, that feels very, very contemporary. It does, which is why what Sartre does with all these arguments, push them to terrifying limits. Yeah. It retains its power to shock and unsettle in the 21st century. Yes. And I think that that's one of the things that mark him out as a fascinating figure and why looking at his influence over the way that he's been interpreted since his death,
你应该根据这些欲望行事，而社会试图遏制它们是错误的，诸如此类。我的意思是，这感觉非常、非常当代。确实如此，这就是为什么萨德用所有这些论点所做的事情，将它们推向了可怕的极限。是的。它在21世纪仍然保持着震惊和不安的力量。是的。我认为这是让他成为一个迷人人物的原因之一，也是为什么审视他在去世后被解读方式的影响，
that every period finds different ways in which he's unsettling. He casts a shadow over different political shibboleths, different political ideals at different stages of the centuries that have followed his death. So we started with a quotation, 120 Days of Sodom. I didn't read the whole quotation because I didn't want the podcast to be cancelled. You said you found that book, you said it was boring at one point because it just goes on and on and on. Have you actually ever read it, made it all the way through? I've never managed to finish 120 Days of Sodom. Because it's huge, isn't it? It's enormous. It's not that huge. Juliet is the one that's
每个时期都发现他令人不安的不同方式。他在他去世后的几个世纪里，在不同的阶段，对不同的政治信条、不同的政治理想投下了阴影。所以我们从一段引文开始，《索多玛120天》。我没有读完整的引文，因为我不想让播客被取消。你说你找到了那本书，你说它在某一点上很无聊，因为它只是没完没了地继续。你真的读过它吗，一直读到底？我从来没有成功读完《索多玛120天》。因为它很大，不是吗？它非常巨大。它没那么大。《朱丽叶》才是那本
really huge, as it were. I mean, it's so difficult to talk about Sard, not strained to kind of turn into Benny Hill. I mean, the thing is, is that Sard was banned in Britain when I was at university. And that was in the wake of the Moores murders because Ian Bradley had a copy of Justine. And in the wake of that, his books were banned. I think it wasn't until 1989 that it came to be published. And I went to San Francisco in that year and found a copy of it there and bought it. It was in a kind of hippie shop, Haight-Ashbury, and tried to read it and couldn't i mean it was you just you just end up feeling sick actually it's not you know having been banned in 1989 it's now a penguin classic so when it came out as a penguin classic i bought it again tried to read it still couldn't and then
真正巨大的，可以说是。我的意思是，谈论萨德太难了，不至于变成本尼·希尔。我的意思是，问题在于，我在大学时萨德在英国是被禁的。那是在莫尔斯谋杀案之后，因为伊恩·布拉德利有一本《瑞斯丁》。在那之后，他的书被禁了。我想直到1989年它才被出版。那一年我去了旧金山，在那里找到了一本并买了它。它是在一家嬉皮商店，海特-阿什伯里，我试着读它，但读不下去，我的意思是，你最终只会感到恶心，实际上，你知道，在1989年被禁之后，它现在是一本企鹅经典。所以当它作为企鹅经典出版时，我又买了一本，试着读它，还是读不下去，然后
i tried to read it again when i wrote about sod for dominion yeah still couldn't finish it so i think it's literally an unreadable book right Right. Well, literally an unreadable book. You can hardly get a more ringing endorsement. Penguin Classics will be delighted with that, Tom. All right. So that's the Marquis de Sade. Actually, we were worried before we started this that it would be a podcast full of absolute depravity
我在写关于萨德的《统治》时又试着读了一次，是的，还是没读完。所以我认为它实际上是一本无法阅读的书。对。好吧，实际上是一本无法阅读的书。你很难得到比这更响亮的背书了。企鹅经典会对此感到高兴的，汤姆。好了。这就是萨德侯爵。实际上，我们在开始之前担心这会是一个充满绝对堕落的播客
and debauchery. But actually, the funny thing is, it wasn't, I don't think. Quite a lot of, I mean, quite a lot. I suppose so. But we had genocide instead. Yes. But actually, the Marquis de Sade is genuinely a much more interesting figure than I had realized.
和放荡。但实际上，有趣的是，它不是，我不这么认为。相当多，我的意思是，相当多。我想是这样。但我们反而有了种族灭绝。是的。但实际上，萨德侯爵确实是一个比我意识到的更有趣的人物。
I think he's a fascinating figure, yeah. And I hope that the listeners are persuaded that it hasn't been mere prurience that has led us to record this episode. No, I don't think so. Right. That's the Marquis de Sade. No doubt sales of 120 days of Sodom will rocket after this. And on that bombshell, we will say goodbye. Au revoir. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
我认为他是一个迷人的人物，是的。我希望听众们相信，引导我们录制这一集并不是单纯的窥淫癖。不，我不这么认为。好了。这就是萨德侯爵。毫无疑问，《索多玛120天》的销量在这次之后会飙升。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们要说再见了。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。